yeah and
i mean people should know that td gammon
was i get would you call it do you like
the terminology of self-play by any
chance
so like systems that learn by playing
themselves just i don't know if it's the
best word
but uh so what's what's the problem with
that term
okay silly it's like the big bang like
it's it's like talking to serious
physicists do you like the term big bang
and
when when it was early i feel like it's
the early days of self-play i don't know
maybe it was used previously but
i think it's been used by only a small
group of people
uh and so like i think we're still
deciding is this
ridiculously silly name a good name for
the cons
potentially one of the most important
concepts in artificial intelligence
okay it depends how broadly you apply
the term so i used the term in my 1996
phd dissertation
wow the actual terms of yeah because
because
tessaro's paper was something like um
training up an expert
backgammon player through self-play so i
think it was in the title of his paper
okay if not in the title it was
definitely a term that he used
there's another term that we got from
that work is rollout so i don't know if
you do you ever hear the term rollout
that's a backgammon term that has now
applied whoa
generally in computers well at least in
ai
because of td gammon yeah that's
fascinating so how is health play being
used now and like why is it does it does
it feel like a more general powerful
concept
sort of the idea of well the machine's
just going to teach itself to be smart
yeah so that's that's where maybe you
can correct me
but that's where you know the
continuation of the spirit and actually
like
literally the exact algorithms of td
gammon are applied
by deep mind and open ai to learn games
that are a little bit more complex
that when i was learning artificial
intelligence go was presented to me
with artificial intelligence the modern
approach
i don't know if they explicitly pointed
to go in those books
uh as like unsolvable kind of thing
like implying that these approaches hit
their limit
in this with these particular kind of
games so something
i don't remember if the book said it or
not but something in my head
or was the professors instilled in me
the idea like this is the limits of
artificial intelligence
of the field like it instilled in me the
idea that
if we can create a system that can solve
the game of go
we've achieved agi that was kind of i
didn't explicitly like
say this but it that was the feeling and
so from i was one of the people that it
seemed
magical when a learning system was able
to
to beat a uh a human
world champion at the game of go and
even more so
from that that was alphago even more so
with alphago zero then kind of renamed
and advanced into alpha zero
beating a world champion or world class
player
without any supervisors learning on
expert games we're doing only through by
playing itself
you